anybody could conceivably die on any
given day and we're all gonna die
eventually
[Applause]
so Lange just makes it far more
immediate you accept the fact that if
anything goes wrong you're going to die
and that's that
[Music]
I wasn't the kind of kid that was into
all kinds of different sports and teams
I didn't have a whole lot of hobbies or
interests I was quite a shy kid bit of a
dark soul I guess living in a van is the
most practical way to be a rock climber
it's pretty civilized really I bought
myself a big white panel then and then
lived in it for nine years
there are tons of things that I want to
do as a climber but they all feel
trivial compared to the idea of free
soloing I'll cab
Oh Capitan was first climbed in 1958 and
that took 46 days of climbing spread
over 16 months to reach the summit
I've dreamt a free Solio cat for ten
years and every year it just looked too
big
it's just a big wall at least a thousand
feet taller than pretty much anything
else that's ever been free soloed in the
world
super intense high-level focus and
difficult climbing for probably four or
five hours quite a long time really
climbing without a rope requires a level
of mastery their opening day
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
climbing the root is not purely a
physical challenge it's also mental I
work to expand my comfort zone until
there is no fear there I shouldn't go up
there unless I'm prepared comfortable
and I'm not going to feel fear
[Music]
I'm not trying to overcome my theater
I'm just trying to step outside of it
[Music]
definitely for me free soloing is as
close to perfection as rock from a guess
and it does feel good to feel perfect
even for breathing
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
humans don't have any particularly
special place on earth certainly no more
so than any of the other creatures
you're on this huge face this
overwhelming world around you and you
feel totally
climbing is a real physical challenge in
the real world it's like man against
nature
you're in this position and no other
humans will ever experience
when you feel like you're climbing the
best that you possibly can
on something that's barely doable that's
pretty close to ideal
there's just so much in life where
you're like oh I'm not good at life but
at least I'm really good at this for a
few hours on our cap I got to actually
experience perfection
you
you